one team wins one team loses and when
you lose you gotta
figure out how to get back on track so
there's no excuses this team hasn't made
any excuses all year we just get to work
and go back there and try to do better
oh they they they did better they got it
together
from three points last week to 46 at
carolina it was a little sluggish at
first the panthers scored first which
ran
the cumulative score from two games to
45 to three but the
buccaneers quickly woke up and they they
dismantled the carolina panthers
um it was exactly what they needed and
you know the excuse was built in because
they spent seven hours on the tarmac
saturday
yesterday trying to get to charlotte
they had no meetings on saturday night
went straight
to bed ronald jones told me when they
they got to carolina
but uh yeah they they according to jones
they watched the film and they threw it
away which i still don't quite
understand i don't know how you throw
away everything that's all digital but
i think it's the point i get they know
who you mean uh
but and they made an agreement among
themselves they were never gonna have
another performance like that
and they they went in the other
direction in a dramatic way
and uh yeah if if you're not capable
of waking up your guys when you have
that many talented players after getting
embarrassed the way you did then
then you have no chance no that's so
they had to do what they did yesterday
chris you're right and i mean we all
thought they had the right leadership to
turn that around after a loss like that
and everything there but they are so
talented
and early on you were kind of going like
like what you said mike you're just
going
man this looks like the bucks from last
week i don't know are they going to be
able to get this together i mean they
were down 14 to seven the panthers
moving the ball
but it was like it was like todd bowles
and the buccaneers defense finally said
all right enough
enough enough enough i've seen enough of
this saints passing system because the
carolina panthers run the same system
pick us apart with these short passes
and it's like they started to pressure
and blitz
and get in the face of the carolina
football team and
the the biggest thing mike that i think
you and i discussed a lot last week that
we saw
yesterday the buccaneers offense got
back to what
made them six and two you know before
they lost the saints and everything
there
which was the double tight end sets and
running the football not getting so
enamored with
you can't match up with all our
receivers we're going to get the shotgun
and throw the football
we've seen brady's been at his best when
there is just a little semblance of a
run game
the play-action pass being so effective
or they keep that tight in to protect
tight end to protect him and i think
that's where you know
we saw a lot of big plays 20 25 yard
completions from them yesterday
and i think it's because of that formula
that that's effective for them
well and the difference yesterday was
they didn't fall into a 28-point hole
like
they did against the saints so they
didn't have to abandon the run but i
think one of the pressure points between
bruce aaron's and tom brady is that
how often do we have antonio brown on
the field how often are we going to be
in three and four receiver sets arians
made it clear last week
he wants to run the ball and when you go
from having
a game where you generated the fewest
rushing attempts
in the 101 season history of the league
and you turn it around like that and you
put the tight ends back out on the field
you do what you have to do to play
winning football that's the bottom line
and
and i think to the extent that there was
any argument
or consternation or tension aryans wins
this one
and if brady just wants to win games and
if he wants to chase championship number
seven
there's a point where you have to say
hey antonio
you know you're gonna get your chances
but not nearly as many
unless mike evans or chris godwin get
injured and then if they get injured
you're going to be on the field all the
time but they they just can't they can't
get away
from what fuels the passing game and
it's the running game
it is it it helps them and brady's
better when he does play action pass and
sucks those linebackers up and makes big
throws
you know and you know mike i think
you're spot on
like just the way this last eight days
played out for them
there's no more argument i don't think
like brady or anybody's gonna go hey
let's get in the shotgun and get three
receivers
you know i think the proof is in the
pudding there you're 100 right and
and even with brady's good day yesterday
yesterday of 28
for 39 for 341 three touchdowns all that
awesome
there there was more there brady was a
little off
and i don't i'm not trying to be
disrespectful or anything
but we we watched together you know
producer matt casey he was sitting next
to me
there was some big throws down the field
for wide open
antonio brown wide open for a long time
wide open there was two or three years
right there was two or three of those so
i think that too where brady's going to
go back and look and go
man yeah we we really can know how to
spread the
spread the field when we play this way
and we put teams in a tough spot
and uh i just think it's their best way
of playing football altogether the bucks
look the best
when they try to play through that run
game and that was impressive yesterday
at one point there was what appeared to
be an awesome throw to chris godwin
where he
basically threw him open and when you
watch the highlight i'm waiting for
peyton manning
to break it all down and tell us that
mike evans was actually the intended
receiver
that one that this one if if manning
breaks this one down i think he might
have a case i think manning was wrong
the first time around but yeah you're
right there was like a
third down throw to the right side and i
think he was throwing to the inside
receiver in mike evans but he missed the
throw
and the outside receiver ended up
catching it uh so you're right that
could be it but they spread the ball
around yesterday i mean we saw gronk and
cameron break
and then of course even with those three
guys at receiver not being on the field
all the time at the same time
hey there was still plenty to go around
and i think that's the kind of stat
line no matter which one of those
receivers has those stats
they'll be able to walk away go we won
and i got the ball enough to where i'm
cool
and let's keep going on and you know
that's uh that's fun i'm sure everybody
they had a fun plane ride home last
night
it brings me back to the point that i
made when they signed antonio brown and
we saw the details of the contract
why are you tying incentives to his
production because you're only setting
the stage for him to
get frustrated because he sees those
limited opportunities
as money that will never make its way
into his bank account you need to come
up with team-based incentives not
individual-based incentives
in order to keep antonio brown on the
right track all right oh oh
let's just say where are we with the
bucks just to button it up like where
are we
you know because there's a game today is
it well i know but that says crazy right
because there we see a team like
carolina who's played
everybody tough and they dominated them
yesterday
dominated i mean the bucks didn't punt
the ball i mean they dominated
so that just where i get back into like
man when they play their best football
they're they're special but it's just a
little bit all over the place
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports